we are an unusual couple
oh i don't think that was ever in
question to me wandam vision have always
been the most
complex compelling avengers they have
this epic love story so i wanted to know
why do you guys think juan and vision
are so perfect for each other elizabeth
i'd love to hear from you first
well i think they're perfect for each
other for like for many ways and for
like a very comic
book our mcu world is we
um which is different from the comics is
we have them
um they both have a piece of the same
thing in their dna
so i feel like there's this thing that
naturally um
physically bonds them the mind stone
and i think that's kind of like this
beautiful representation of when we have
this like unspoken connection with
people
where you feel like you've always been a
part of them and they physically
actually do have something that ties
them together
they're literally soul mates and i so i
think there's something unspoken about
it
um as well as this like beautiful
journey that paul gets to go on where
he's a robot trying to make sense of
what
feelings are and what feeling love is
and her being this
very empathetic um deep feeling
woman helping him along with that
it's just such an innocent expression of
love between the two of them
i think that's right i also think that
what makes them such a great unit both
as a fighting unit and just as a couple
is that you know uh they complete each
other but in a good way
you know they meet each other at the
best bits of themselves and i know lots
of couples
who complete each other just not
necessarily in good ways
[Laughter]
you know what i mean they're like yeah
they fit like this but
at all the good points of themselves not
like the
shouty passionate
yeah i know right if only we could go to
a store and buy mine stones you know and
then just like pick them off the shelf
that'd be amazing
elizabeth what was it like for you to
finally get to dive deep
into wanda as she grows more and more
powerful
it was amazing i mean i i also just love
the opportunity
as an actor to get to play in this genre
um of sitcom like i just
every to do that and then through this
whole show we're exploring
everything that she has experienced and
processing
that we have seen and that we haven't
seen um
and then we watch her grow from it so
there's some
there's it became like a whole rebirth
and um
for my like love and appreciation for
this character after six years of
playing
her and and now i'm i feel like i'm more
sense of ownership with her because of
this time
right and i i was listening to an
interview you did and
it's cool because when you were first
introduced to this character what you
loved about her was like her origin
story in the comics so it's really
awesome to like get you watch
to get to watch you sort of just play
that out um
paul with vision you know as we get to
see more of him
we're seeing his humanity grow and the
show is very much a comedy so what sides
of vision were you excited to portray
i was slightly anxious at the beginning
of this to think well is he is he going
to be the same
guy and how do i keep him the same guy
and then i realized actually vision's
been changing the whole time
he's sort of but you seem born and he's
omnipotent
yet naive and that was fun to play with
and then by
civil war he's really on this journey to
try and understand what
humanity is what's the whole deal with
love and all of that and then
by uh you know infinity war
he is uh you know arguably and
ironically
you know one of the most human
characters
in it and you know he's a bit of ultron
he's a bit of jarvis he's a bit of tony
stark now
we're throwing in a little bit of uh
dick van dyke in and that's okay
as long as as long as the center
of him stays which is that he's just
sort of thoroughly
decent and honorable and is
and now really exists for
wonder his soulmate yeah
did you paul did you think vision was
dead forever like did you think you'd
ever be playing him again after phase
three
i was about
85 percent certain i was dead forever
yeah i read that um you know that kevin
called you to the studio
and you oh yeah you were sort of getting
that's 100 percent like i
i i got the phone call i you know i
didn't
my contract was up i'd just been killed
twice
it felt pretty definitive and then and
then the boss rang up and told me to
come in the office and
we all know what that means right and so
i
um i looked at my wife and i went i
think uh
i think yeah we've done those expensive
vacations and
um and and uh so i went in and i i just
want to make everybody feel comfortable
and so i said look
it's totally fine i totally get it it's
been a great run and thank you so much
and they went are you quitting and i
went no aren't you firing
me and they went no we're going to pitch
you a tv show
oh i'm in and
then i didn't listen to the pitch
because i was just so relieved
obviously you know one division is the
show where we get to explore
american sitcom you know through the
decades meets mcu film
which decade was the funnest or the
funniest for you guys to dive into and
play
elizabeth it's so hard to pick
which one was more enjoyable because
they're all very ridiculous in their own
ways
which allow them to be beyond
fun and um i
specifically though loved um
the 70s because of its absurd
um false representation of an
aspirational family
whilst being pregnant having
contractions and giving birth
because it is the most unrealistic
version
of a birthing experience one can have
so i i enjoyed uh chewing up that
scenery for those moments
i would agree i loved all of that i
loved um
playing with those tropes and and him
and and vision getting so excited that
that
wonder needs to get him to breathe even
though she's the one having contractions
i loved all of that stuff and i love i
really love doing the
the title sequence um uh montage
which uh which um
really lent itself to what it turns out
is elizabeth olsen and my strong suit
which is over acting wildly
for montages your your
your mugging on the tandem is uh
will be a lasting memory for me
it's always how to find the camera
watching this show you just know that
the both of you are having like an
absolute blast like it just seems like
literally the most fun job an actor can
hack
i'm not just us i mean and not just the
cast you know i mean i i'm
i pull um jess hall who is a
brilliant cinematographer who i've
worked with
three or four times and uh for him
to be able to you know really nail
all of these different looks for the for
the different eras
he was uh he was having uh everybody
it was just a really fun set and i think
you're right i think you can feel it as
you watch it but it is also like
simultaneously one of the hardest jobs
we've all had to do because of how often
everything had to change
so it's really demanding on um art
direction it's really demanding on
the lighting always changing based on
the decade the lens is changing based on
the decade the costumers
i mean you think about the exterior
scenes and they would have to work
overnight
just changing something from the 70s to
the 80s because the picket fence the
flowers the paint all of these things
are going to have to change
depending on the decade so it was so
hard but because we were having such a
good time it made it all worth it and we
all cared so much about the project so
it
was
it was just a it was a gift this show it
was it's like birth it was like so hard
you forget the hard bits and you're just
just remember that the gift you get
afterwards
this child you have to raise it is such
a gift i was on the receiving end of it
our fans are massive fans of vision they
think he has so much sex appeal
why do you guys think vision is like the
zaddy of the avengers
what is zaddy i like that term it's like
the daddy it's like the internet's daddy
version
you know yeah yeah
what is it i gotta tell my wife what is
it
the zaddy zaddy
i'm terribly flattered how lovely
i have no idea why it's about perfectly
trying to climb into my costume and if
you could see me
climbing out of my costume at the end
you might you might not they might not
feel that way
wanda what's up who are you
i don't know first of all you look
beautiful and i have to just say when i
saw you in the show
and i i love you in mad men i was like
this
person can rock period pieces like no
other person i've ever seen
thank you it did feel very um like a
throwback to my mammon days
definitely i loved it so
obviously your character monica has a
super dope backstory in the comics and i
know a lot of people are going to be
wondering
how closely does your monika rambo
resemble the comic book version
um well i can speak to her personality
um not really about what her journey is
gonna be
um in the mcu but it's personality wise
i definitely went back to the comics
to learn about who this woman was how
she handles conflict how she
um has grown uh well not grown but
um who what her story arc is right
and then i used that to inform how
my monika has grown since we last saw
her in captain marvel
when she was a young girl um so i
definitely took
the um what i really loved about monica
in the comics is how ambitious she is
and akira akbar also um
did a great job of portraying that in
her version of monica
and um so her ambition how very
unapologetic
she is to take up space and to be
herself um she's very
bold and brave and so i loved all of
that about her and i wanted to find
where possible ways to um
bring that to our wanda uh
monica here in one division right
right so bold ah we need it i'm so
excited
obviously you mentioned you know captain
marvel we haven't seen monica since she
was a little girl in captain marvel so
what has she been up to
since captain marvel well you will find
out what monica's
up to uh since captain marvel where she
was a little girl
throughout the course of wanda vision we
definitely dive into
um her back story and what's been going
on for her
over the past years and um yeah
we get into that tbd
so you know when we look at the comics
monica and wanda
are two of the strongest superheroes in
the entire universe so
what do you think fans can expect to see
when these two women come together in
this new series of wand division
i'm trying not to give anything away and
i'm like i don't know
we we will find out who monica
is and what she's capable of or not
and um that's all i can say
i know it's like when you sign your life
away
relationship with wanda is it will be
revealed in the course of the show
right can you tell us maybe what aspects
of your character you're excited
to to explore in in the upcoming
projects because we know you're going to
be you know
captain marvel too without giving
anything away it's like you haven't seen
anything in one division so
i it's it's hard to say what i'm looking
forward to
carrying over if you don't know that yet
so
not really i am excited just as the
actress to join
brie and iman and see you know
what the putting these three superheroes
together
um carol danvers captain marvel miss
marvel and monica rambo
what what will become and happen in uh
that film but yeah the rest we're just
gonna have to wait a few weeks before we
can really talk about it
okay well we do know that this show you
know one division from what we've seen
in the trailers is like the american
sitcom
through the decades meets like an mcu
movie so what was it like
you know playing these different decades
and is there one that was your favorite
you know to sort of dive into and play
so we
definitely so the in one division we
pay homage to the different decades of
american television through sitcom
and i actually got to watch um my
castmates
do um the 50s episode i got to be a part
of the live
audience and so that was a really
exciting just watching how much
um specificity and detail it has gone
into each episode um being mindful and
true to
its time period was really really
exciting um they just put
so much effort into each episode in each
decade
and then my favorite to be in i would
say was the 70s
that was pretty you know that was pretty
cool
[Laughter]
it just was it's it made me come outside
of myself and what i'm used to doing and
i've actually never done sitcom in real
life so
being a part of a sitcom um
was a very different experience and
flexed
required me to flex very different
muscles uh in my
uh to in my instrument so that was that
was fun
yeah that's cool that you've never done
that before and and now like in the mcu
i know i mean i know you've been in like
some pretty iconic projects but
that must have been like so much you
know to to sort of like
bring out of yourself yeah i mean you
you hear marvel you're like yeah guys i
signed up to be thrown across a room and
to
i don't know cgi some stuff but then to
get the opportunity to actually
you know do all of those things and uh
check something else off my wish list of
as an actor which is
being in a sitcom and being a part of
that structure and learning
how to navigate that that art form that
was really cool
i was not expecting that when i heard i
was joining the mcu
what was it like working with elizabeth
and paul they seemed like they'd be
really i mean
just watching the show you're like these
people are just having so much fun so
what was it like
like physically being there lizzy and
paul
man i am so so blessed to have been able
to
come into the mcu alongside these
two beautiful human beings and
and as artists they're just so
they're so generous and so um
so good like i don't even know what else
to say like there's like watching them
be able to
explore the relationship between wanda
and vision
with more space and freedom was really
really
um exciting for me particularly being a
fan of their relationship before i even
joined
the mcu so um that was really exciting
and they're just very
kind people and funny
and yeah so it was it was a pleasure
to go and be with them and create with
them
you know you mentioned like getting the
call for marvel
you know and like agreeing to get thrown
across
a room like did you have to go into any
specific training
for your character i did not and i
probably
should have um yeah no
i there was no advanced training
but moving forward i will
definitely get some training
you know it's just a very odd
thing to the sensation of being lifted
like
on a wire so that you can float to you
know get thrown across the room or
something like you see in the trailer
um it's very weird
and odd and not natural and
that is something you you should
probably practice for a while to so that
it becomes natural so when you're
actually acting with your scene partner
you're not worried about this
uncomfortable strap
that is poking and prodding at some
business it should not be touching
um you can focus on the matter at hand
um so yeah i didn't get any training but
i
will moving forward
um okay so you get you know you've done
all these huge projects
you get the call you know to come to the
mcu what was that like
and then also like diving into monica
knowing
and and this is just me saying this that
she is a very integral part of the
future of the mcu like she's kind of a
really big deal
so walk me through like all those
emotions and and sort of like entering
the
the marvel cinematic universe well
when i found out it was monica rambo who
i'd gotten the part for her
i was definitely i was already familiar
with her
as a superhero just because previously
like years ago
fans had started casting me fan casting
me as her
and i was like who is this and so let me
look it up and so i did like a brief
look up of her and the understanding of
her and i was like oh wow she is a
badass would love to do it probably
never will happen
so when i found out it was actually
happening i was like whoa
what um really excited and
i you know i don't know how she fits
into
the future of the mcu any more than what
we've all been
told which is she joins captain marvel
too um
but i i i knowing her rich history in
the comics or
you know barely scratching the surface
having a general understanding of it
i'm still learning and figuring all of
that out but um
i i i am truly honored for the
opportunity to tell her story and to
bring her to life and
so we'll see we'll see what happens that
is so dope that people were fan casting
you
and now here we are that's wild
thank y'all thank you for putting it
into the atmosphere and claiming it for
me
have you guys talked about when you're
going to shoot captain marvel 2 have you
already shot some stuff
no we have i can say we haven't started
shooting and i don't know
when we will start you know it's very
interesting times we're in so
i imagine they'll start as soon as they
can
when it's safe for everybody so we'll
see
am i dead no why would you think that
because you are
catherine i'm so excited to talk to you
i mean i've just seen you in
so many things it's this is very
exciting for me i
it's really cool that you play you know
agnes the nosey neighbor and i was
thinking of the concept of neighbor and
how that's just taken on a whole new
meaning in quarantine
but what was it like playing the nosy
neighbor was it fun
yes i mean it's it's the best it's the
best i mean i couldn't have dreamt
a more dreamy part in the mcu than this
one like it was so fun
to be able to go from decade to decade
to be able to like play with different
with with different genres of comedy
to be and wigs forget it love that and
then also to be able to just like
you know it's always the neighbor it's
it's just always about the timing you
know
whatever that neighbor appears and so
that that was it was just like
a blast to be able to like to play with
that
and to become like pals on screen and
off with lizzy like it was
such a treat oh what was it like working
with her and paul
i adore her i mean i just adore her like
i just think she's one of the greatest
and
we had um it was a real uh i will hold
this experience like really
close to my heart it was a special one
um and
and paul as well he's hilarious
hilarious
and we i mean that first episode that
was shot in front of a studio audience
was
i mean legit we were running back and
forth behind the scenes like
behind the set just like as if we were
putting on a play like
what you don't see is us like quick
changing grabbing props
running into it and to be make sure we
were by this door for this entrance
like we rehearsed it for uh like for a
long time
to make sure that we could on the day
perform it like a play in front of that
audience and so
in terms of like um just just in terms
of
of ensemble building like we felt like
we were in a little theater company
and i was like and then i kept having to
step back and be like i'm in that this
is the
this is in the mcu
it was so awesome it was very
trippy very trippy and you're right you
know
paul and vision is really funny it's fun
seeing him
it's fun seeing you know the human side
of him come out and grow the more and
more we see him but what was it like
tell us more about what it was like
shooting in front of a live studio
audience and how that sort of maybe like
elevated the material
well exactly that i mean i think you
know
i i think because because we were
afforded the
the luxury which a lot of things don't
productions don't have we were allowed
because it was it was going to be filmed
live like this little play
we had the luxury of being able to
rehearse and
that is something that was really
quickly bonding for all of us because we
all knew we were just going to throw
ourselves
out there and see what happened on that
day in front of like a lot of people
and um you know the jack shaver who
wrote the
the script wrote something that was is
so tonally
perfect to the like to that era and it's
those jokes are very they're not cynical
like there's something like really
there's something that's so charming
about it
um and that was i think like that the
trick
was to not step outside of it and
comment on it like
performance wise but just to stay inside
inside of it and um
that's hard you know it's difficult i
you know i i definitely like
come from like an impro improvisey you
know turns out like i'm a little bit of
a cynic
like it's hard like there was something
that was so charming about just being
in in the purity of that um
that was and just the once those lap
those first couple laughs started
happening from the audience because we
honestly were like i don't know
are people going to laugh because this
is like really i don't know like
who are these audience members like
what's happening and then once it was
like
it was all so surreal it was so surreal
but once it started happening it was
like we all went on this ride together
like
we all just had this like beautiful you
know
couple of hours this audience and us and
the camera people and the
props and everybody and it was like i'll
just hold that day to my heart like it
was really
um magic you're right well well
you could definitely feel your magic
coming off screen and you're right there
is a purity to it and you nailed it
because you don't want to be a parody of
this thing you want to like really be it
and it was just so so cool and i know
you keep saying you can't believe you're
the mcu
i read that you you were saying that you
think your kids must think you're
so cool but now you are in the mcu so
how would you like to see agnes involved
in the mcu
like moving forward oh i mean in in any
way
i mean i would just love her to be just
like in you know in any
any film just kind of knocking into the
door with a cup of tea
for anybody with with a lot of unearned
uh unasked for advice and a lot of uh
nosiness and suspicions like i just feel
like
i don't know how the nosy neighbor is
going to figure into the mcu
but but i i loved i loved playing her in
this so madly
right and what's cool is that we we got
a little glimpse of the fact that you
get to play
it looks like multiple different
characters so you know watching
the first couple episodes there's
definitely inspiration from bewitched
yeah you have scarlet witch and then we
see you
sort of wearing this witch hat letting
out this amazing cackle
why do you think witches are so
important to this show
well i mean i i i don't know about that
but i do
know that i mean it's her it's wanda's
or it's wanda's origin story so i guess
we get to go
you know we get to dig into that and i
think we all know who she is so that
that i think
totally what was it like shooting
um all the different decades you know
that must have been
so much fun i keep hearing your voice in
my head actually catherine when people
are like what'd you think of the show
i'm like oh it's a gas
like get like your voice in my head
i love the way you said it you're
welcome or should i say i'm so sorry
say you're welcome and i'm sorry to all
my friends because that's like my new
favorite phrase what was your favorite
decade and what was it like shooting
you know i think that the 50s were
probably my favorite
to shoot just because of what we talked
about before because of the interaction
with the audience because it was the
first time together
and because we were like it felt like we
were like
just like on the on the just jumping off
this cliff together
like is this gonna work like you know it
was such a huge
leap and we had no idea like how it's
gonna land and so i think that that
thrill that'll that will be my favorite
um
uh visually you know i'm a kid of the
80s so i i love that big hair
and i love you know nice all that stuff
that's so funny everyone i asked that
question to you said the 70s which is
like so hilarious i'm like they might
say
i'm shooting the 70s yeah yeah hilarious
yeah so obviously you know this show is
like
nothing we've ever seen before it's like
totally its own thing can you give us
like
two different references to describe
this show like is it like
i dream of jeannie meets i don't know
something else like what
what what are catherine's like two
different crosses and references today
yeah i would definitely say
to me it would be like
leave it to beaver slash twilight zone
or like you know depending on the era it
would just be like
insert your favorite family
sitcom growing up meets twilight zone
the wonder years needs twilight zone
malcolm in the middle meets twilight you
can do any sitcom you want it
meets twilight zone
i think something's wrong here
kevin i was watching um the last time i
talked to you which was an interview we
did on the purple carpet at endgame you
were telling me how awkward you felt
doing those interviews and i was
thinking to myself like i wonder how
kevin feels doing these zoom interviews
you know what it might be a little less
awkward uh
because i'm just in my base
um and we're used to it now but you know
it's it's actually the opposite i now
miss i was taking for granted
that purple carpet was amazing and maybe
i should just get over it
um because being together and being with
all those people and all those fans
and all those um reporters is
a privilege and i will not uh i will not
take it granted
again after this after this none of us
will
um okay so i'll get right to it one
division our first
official installment into phase four of
the mcu
how much did kovid shift things and
where will this show take us into the
future
well covet shifted a lot like it did for
for the entire world
um mainly in just the order in which
some of
our of our projects were released
uh one division was going to be our
second disney plus show
uh falconer soldier first based on some
of the rescheduling
one division of courses first which in
hindsight
is actually great and is actually better
because it's
our first foray into television being
this love letter to the format of
television
um makes all the sense in the world um
and we had to change and adjust the way
everybody has
we do interviews like this we do uh
uh development meetings like this we do
editorial meetings like this we do our
department meetings like this
like this being uh uh remotely and the
production process itself
um uh has gotten back on track
in a way that is um has remarkably
adapted
to safety measures and and
the the the masks and on productions
it's not just masks it's sunglass it's
uh glasses but goggles
it's face plates and everybody just
accepts it
and does the work in a safe uh in a
safer way as possible
and uh other than that
uh creatively um
it hasn't shifted sort of our goals or
our um
dreams of what of what these projects
can be it just as it did for the whole
world delayed us
and what like you were saying it's
really great that one division is first
i remember you saying one time that one
division is one of the most powerful
beings
in the universe so which of her powers
are you like most stoked and excited to
explore in this series
of one um well well sort of
uh sort of all of them but all of it as
an extension of her
um experiences that's what that's what
i'm excited about
is um she's gone through so much in the
movies
that we get to finally tap into that and
what would that mean
and also further discovering who she is
and what she can do and where it all
came from
um is fun and what and what
we could talk more about once everyone's
seen every episode but we can't
now right well we can talk about you
know monica rambo
now being on the show which is super
super exciting getting to see more of
her
how integral are monica and wanda going
to be to the future of the mcu
well um uh very we've already announced
that uh
will mexiwanda uh after this uh series
she's a big part of
uh teaming up with doctor strange in his
movie the in the multiverse of madness
and tiana paris will be joining brie
larson uh
in captain marvel 2. so so we already
have um
have big plans for where they where they
go
after this uh after this introduction
which is uh great fun
yeah and it's just awesome because it
feels like women are really gonna be
taking the lead in phase four which i am
super stoked for
um but watching wanda vision you know
kevin it's very much an american tv
sitcom and it's hilarious it feels very
family centered
are we going to be able to see any of
wanda's other family members like let's
say quicksilver
or magneto well
yes she's got a lot of family members in
the comics um
this is this is uh yeah more about that
relationship with vision
and more about uh about that dynamic and
that
and that uh the relationship of that
couple in the evolving relationship of
that
of that couple um and how that
grows goes and evolves and unfolds
yeah but is there a possibility maybe
that we might see other family members
uh there are other characters in other
episodes of this
show um who they are what they are
not uh not worth discussing right right
kevin i want to ask you about the
multiverse because you know you
confirmed that one division is directly
connected to dr strange to
the multiverse was teased a little bit
at the end of
spider-man far from home you know you
know what can you tell us about
that playing a part in the future of mcu
well i mean the title of the next doctor
strange movie is doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness
so that is that is our biggest clue that
that um
that movie will embrace um the
multiverse and the madness uh therein
uh very directly there are as we always
like to to do
connections before and after that which
will remain to be seen and discovered
um but it it seemed appropriate that it
would be doctor strange
that takes that on in the most direct uh
in the most direct way
nice and this show is just so
stylistically different you know i was
watching it kevin and i was like my
mom's gonna love this like this is how
i'm gonna get my mom into the mcu i'm so
excited
it's stylistically so different than
anything we've ever seen in the mcu
can fans expect like these sort of
really distant
distinct approaches to like these future
shows we're gonna see on disney plus
through the mcu
i hope so i mean it's um we uh
you know i've i always say that that if
you look at taika with td's thor or john
favreau's iron man
or james guns guardians or jocelyn's
avengers or joan anthony's avengers
um uh peyton's
ant-man um and certainly coogler's
panther
they all have tonal distinctions they
all have superheroes in them but they
all have
are totally distinct none perhaps as
clearly and obviously as a black and
white 50s sitcom necessarily
but we always try to do that and that
will continue in the movies close
jaws um eternals coming up just destined
credence
shank chin the legend of the ten rings
um uh kate shortlands
uh black widow which i can't wait for
people to see
um all uniquely distinct from one
another
and certainly continuing that with uh
with uh our disney plus shows loki
is a very unique crime thriller starring
tom hiddleston we've announced that
she-hulk is a half-hour legal comedy
um we love to keep taking these
characters to uh
to new places and all of it inspired by
stuff from the comics
because the comics um of course have a
huge
depth of uh storytelling styles and
characters
which for people who really are immersed
in read them can uh uh
understand that respect that yeah i love
it when i was reading that about
she-hulk i'm like is this gonna be like
law and order like super cool
was there a favorite decade um that you
that you had in in wanda vision that's
what i'll offer you to dive into
i love athletics i love the um the
sort of uh 60s early 70s sherwood
schwartz
uh uh brady bunch era i love the
bewitch dick van dyke two bed in the
bedroom um
black and white uh era they all
are are uh unique and and fun and it's
uh in those first three episodes it's
only just starting so that's also
exciting is people are going to
see more week to week i recently read
that you
tapped mike waldron ep of loki to
write your upcoming star wars project
which i'm so excited for
what stories are you stoked to explore
in that universe
uh the all i will say is is uh waldron
um we were big fans of from his rick and
morty um
episodes he came in and created and
developed for television the loki series
and did such an amazing job that we've
brought him on we brought him on to the
multiverse of madness doctor strange
sequel which is what he's actually
working on now
uh anything else is uh rumors
to be discussed at another time
matt it's such a pleasure to talk to you
massive fan of like almost
everything you've done um obviously the
topic of discussion here is
one division one division is a show you
know where you have the american tv
sitcom
meets the marvel cinematic universe
stylistically i can't think of two
things that are
more like different or opposite of each
other so how did you approach
balancing you know american tv sitcom
and
the mcu it's a great question one of the
things i love about marvel studios is
it's risk taking
and their original storytelling and who
would have ever thought that after iron
man you would see something that gardens
of guardians of the galaxy
or thor ragnarok and so what is the mcu
is a constantly evolving thing and
obviously here comes one division to
continue to shake that up
um we were focused on telling
a love story really first and foremost
this is about wanda and vision this
incredible couple
that we've all come to know and love
even in
relatively short amount of screen time
in these avengers movies they've managed
to be
charming and funny and sweet and of
course they've suffered
great loss and so this story is about
that love story that romance that kind
of drags us through so even as we play
with style and tone and go to different
genres
that is the through line that's the
thing that pulls you through
right such an epic love story i love it
you're right you're absolutely right i
was just talking to kevin and he was
saying you know based off
who the director is that's what the
style of of the thing is whether it's
black panther or wand division
how did you you know did you have a
different approach when shooting scenes
for rwanda versus shooting scenes with
vision and like how did you want to tell
their stories
both separate and together you know we
we dove into these
really specific sitcom world and wanted
to be as authentic as possible
we didn't want to feel like we were
doing parody or spoof
and so that meant a lot of research for
for me for my designers
everyone on the team and especially the
actors because they had to capture the
spirit of the comedy
and the style so we worked with dialect
coaches and movement coaches and
and all of that to try to be as accurate
as we could be but ultimately we were
creating
our own show one division our own show
in the 50s and then that own our show
continued on into the 60s and the 70s
and we borrowed from a lot of great
shows like dick van dyke and i love lucy
and bewitched and i dream of jeannie
but in the end we were trying to create
our own show just kind of osmosing and
borrowing
all those different styles yeah and when
you take a step back it's like you
really did that it really does feel like
its own thing
what's cool for you though matt is like
you you started
and grew up around sitcoms like your
entire childhood so this must have been
a really cool
like walk down memory lane for you i
first wanted to ask you about what it
was like shooting in front of a live
studio audience
it really was a trip uh you know down
memory lane and
and part therapy also as well you know
all of this past be like oh my gosh
um uh but it was great you know because
i i got a chance to
to shoot even on the same back lot where
i shot this show just the 10 of us for
many years we shot at warner brothers
ranch on the
on this very famous sitcom street called
blondie street which has the partridge
family house and
i dream of jeannie and bewitched and so
on and so there i was in this place i
used to skateboard when i was you know
10 11 12 years old
shooting this show that was honoring you
know the history of television so the
ghosts of my own past the ghosts of
television past all together
um and then yeah live live studio
audience you know i remembered the
rhythm of my life back then was the
rhythm of
a sitcom show you know it was monday
tuesday wednesday rehearsal thursday
camera blocking friday the big tape day
and then it all started again the
following week
and so here we were approximating that
um at least you know for our first
episode which we did in front of a live
audience and
and it was fun to kind of uh you know
orchestrate all of those elements from
the other side of the camera
there really is nothing like putting on
a show in front of an audience and uh it
changes the way the actors are it
changes the energy in the room
the pace everything you you're
introducing another character
and those shows that taped in front of a
live audience that were our touchstones
like
lucy and like dick van dyke they did it
in front of an audience and so we needed
to as well
yeah and you can tell right you can feel
that energy everything feels bigger it
sort of like elevates the material
i was also reading that you did
extensive research you interviewed
people who
used to put on these shows you read
books i think you gave the actors like a
crash course and american tv sitcoms
can you share a little bit about what
your biggest inspiration was i know you
mentioned a couple shows but
i think you like sat down with dick van
dyke and and um
and kevin feige we did we had the
greatest lunch of all time
um uh one that i will certainly remember
to be there with both of these heroes
of mine um at disneyland we did it
during the weekend of d23 we've been
trying to figure out when we could
schedule and they were honoring um
dick van dyke then at d23 so we sat down
at club 33 above pirates of the
caribbean so
there we were meeting with the ultimate
sort of disney legend of the past with
kevin a new
disney legend of the present um and it
was really fun
and um we we got a chance to tell him
how much his work
meant to us and also to ask him you know
what was the special sauce how did it
work how did you create
this show that is still just as good
today as it was back then you know how
do you make something so timeless
um and also how do you make room to do
something that silly and fun
and he's such an amazing physical
comedian how do you do
all of that while still feeling like
you're telling a real true story
um so that it it's something that
everyone can relate to and it's not just
goofiness for goofiness sake and he was
wonderful and generous
and told us all sorts of wonderful bits
of wisdom that we used
um but yeah we talked to lots of
different people we um our special
effects coordinator who is amazing this
guy dan sudic
actually came up under the people who
did the special effects for bewitched
and i dream of genie
so he had direct knowledge and
experience with wires and rods and all
of this and so
when i asked dan to bring that back it
was like dusting off an old lost musical
instrument and
figuring out how to make it work again
and it was really fun it's so charming
to see things
flying through the air in front of your
face on wires and rods
it's honestly amazing i i found it
really interesting to read too that it
was like a mix between that and cg
how some of some of the rods were or you
know wires were taken out i just think
it's like so so cool you guys did
let's talk about the decades what was it
like directing you know
all these different decades and which
one was your favorite they
all had their charms and you know i love
the live studio audience who doesn't
love that i'm a theater director too so
it's really fun to kind of put on a show
um but the 70s you know the style
the color it's hard to beat that you
know it really is and that was my
favorite set
probably as well the 70s family home um
was just one that i could hang out with
all the time you know what's crazy i've
interviewed
like the cast and everybody said the 70s
even kevin like what was it you got you
know is there a story or day from set
that pops up in memory like why do you
think that was like everyone's favorite
you know it's just it's such a bold
decade and
everyone looks so great and the wigs and
the clothes
and the you know the it's just the
colorful world it just it's like a giant
pick-me-up
just being in that world yeah it's cool
um i also want to ask you you know
you've directed episodes for
game of thrones the boys is there
you know is there a difference or a
different way that you approach
directing drama and superhero drama
it's a good question i also do a lot of
comedies like it's always sunny in
philadelphia
yeah um i lived this kind of strange
schizophrenic life where
jumping around these different styles
and then one division was a chance to be
sort of schizophrenic 24 7 on the show
by its very nature um but i think
directing sort of is directing so you
know i come from theater too and in
theater
you're expected to work at summerstock
and do the musical the shakespeare play
and the knoll coward and the brand new
play
and that's just what it is and you kind
of adjust
your approach depending on the material
you know and yeah it's a little bit more
complicated
when you have to deal with the effects
and things like that but
really i don't know you know magic
tricks on wires and rods is just as hard
as dragons let me tell you
and i think the hardest thing of all is
comedy really um because
wow i mean something that works that
also feels grounded i think
comedy requires more precision than
anything else
this is our home then let's fight for it
[Music]
you